à fort-de-france plus de 50 millimètres
d'eau sont tombés dans la nuit de jeudi
à vendredi
mais eric habitants de la résidence
depuis trente ans n'a jamais vu cela
bon j'ai jamais vu ça de ma vie c'est la
première fois ça m'a dit philippe et
quand j'ai vu ça hier matin très tôt les
autorités sont venues les spécialistes
sont passés tout cela donc je pense
qu'ils vont faire le nécessaire le plus
rapidement possible mais c'est vrai que
dans l'immeuble n'a pas été rassuré
combats dans le quartier les riverains
s'interrogeaient yat-il infiltrations
d'eau souterraine ce parking est il
menacé ou la zone toute entière est elle
finalement instable je pense qu on va se
passer si on voit ce qui s'est passé
de leurs côtés d'anna la zone de la jab
est là donc on s'est dit que bon ça doit
bouger
je pense que ne veulent pas
faire peur aux gens mais tu sais
s'inquiète plus dans ce quartier ben
c'est à dire que j habite mais enfin ils
sont scolarisés
donc est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre à
d'autres phénomènes de ce type de choses
des choses plus graves en fait c'est ce
que j'aimerais savoir avoir des réponses
en tout cas parce que s des coïncidences
à je ne sais pas
dans le même secteur ça fait beaucoup de
choses un petit peu similaire donc
est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre à d'autres
dégâts de ce type
s il ya des gens informés sur les causes
et puis quelles mesures prendre
terrains et bâtiments sont propriétés de
la simard qui tentent de limiter la
panique par la présence de son directeur
ce matin le dieu nous avons
effectivement une visite avec le
géotechnicien sur place
mais je dirais que on pourrait en tout
cas plutôt penser effectivement à jeudi
radio de surface et l'équipement dont
quelques uns ont traîné
c'est en lucarne qui est quand même
relativement terre battue mais je dirais
qu'il ya il ya des ordres donc il faut
effectivement il dirait trouver la cause
est en tout cas et intervenir dans les
meilleurs délais pour faire cesser sur
les autres les riverains eux pensent
bien et des eaux d'infiltration à
bordeaux le marché dit qu'il aimerait
garder à l'esprit les drames du
lotissement soleil levant françois puis
demande calebasse à fort de france
de telles inquiétudes ici sont elles
justifiées pour l'heure aucune fissure
n'est visible sur le bâtiment